[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 une édition pour faire
le tour de l'actualité locale et
régionale tout de suite les titres de ce
mardi 2 avril trois bus électriques à
saint quentin en yvelines ils sont en
circulation depuis hier sur le réseau
stibus dans le secteur de maurepas
elancourt ce sont les premiers véhicules
du genre à être mise en place en grande
couronne par ile-de-france mobilité le
groupe ratp
une volonté d'aller vers des transports
plus écologiques toute cette semaine la
rédaction de tv 60,18 se penche sur
l'union européenne le scrutin pour
désigner ces députés se tient le 26 mai
prochain après les enjeux des élections
hier focus ce soir sur les candidats en
france une quinzaine de liste s'est déjà
déclarée et d'autre pourrait suivre et
puis la biennale d'architecturé de
paysage sera organisée à versailles une
première édition qui se déroulera du 4
mai au 13 juillet dans la cité royale au
programme série de conférences
d'expositions sur les enjeux de la ville
de demain une conférence de presse se
tenait ce matin à paris pour présenter
l'événement et deux invités également en
plateau le président du parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
yves vandewalle le pnr vient de lancer à
la ligue l'aiguillage un lieu pour
favoriser l notamment les modes de
transports alternatifs et nous parlerons
également de tous à lille une événement
de porte est ouverte à lille de loisirs
est de saint quentin en yvelines ce
week-end avec guillaume durand
mais avant de développer ses titres à la
visite ce matin de deux membres du
gouvernement dans les yvelines la
secrétaire d'état aux personnes
handicapées sophie cluzel et son
homologue à la protection de l'enfance
adrien taquet était au centre
hospitalier de versailles andré mignot
et déplacements dans le cadre de la
journée mondiale de l'autisme
l'établissement est équipé d'un
dispositif d'intervention précoce en
autisme le gouvernement lui vient de
mettre en place la plateforme autisme
info service pour mieux informer et
orienter les familles ainsi que leur
entourage
vous les avez peut-être aperçu ou même
déjà emprunté trois nouveaux bus 100 %
électrique ont été mis en circulation
dès hier à saint quentin en yvelines ils
ont un design plus moderne et son est
silencieux les premiers véhicules
du genre en grande couronne francilienne
marylène iapichino vous emmène à bord
trois nouveaux bus avec des sièges bleus
pour les places traditionnelles rouge
pour celles réservées aux personnes
prioritaires des lampes à led et même
des ports usb ile-de-france mobilité et
la ratp présenter les véhicules vendredi
29 mars
voilà donc voilà la prise la prise de
charge donc là vous branchez le bus
comme comme une voiture plus que leur
design extérieur la nouveauté vient
surtout de ce qu'ils ont sous le capot
des batteries les bus du constructeur
français sont 100% électrique
nous rentrons aujourd'hui dans une
nouvelle ère de transition énergétique
et de véhicules propres et c'est là pour
nous l'occasion de rentrer dans cette
nouvelle ère aussi d'apprendre ces
matériels roulants qui sont nouveaux et
nouvelles technologies et d'en profiter
pour que nos conducteurs ça ne s'adapte
à cette nouvelle de technologie
aujourd'hui on a des véhicules qui
arrivent on va avoir une expérimentation
sur des bus à hydrogène dans quelques
mois
et donc c'est important parce que on
peut pas continuer de france a tourné
avec des véhicules diesel twitter tout à
250 km d'autonomie pour des bus qui
circulent en moyenne entre 180 et 220 km
par jour
ils seront rechargées au dépôt chaque
soir les chauffeurs apprennent dès à
présent à pratiquer une conduite
économique
ils vont récupérer l'énergie ont
rechargé les batteries vers vous avez
une conduite économique
orange et rouge
sur le gâteau ces trois bus sont les
premiers du réseau ile de france à être
mises en circulation de 12 mètres de
long ils peuvent accueillir 85 voyageurs
c'est un honneur pour 5 octobre que la
région nokia qu'à financer l'intégralité
de ses bus voilà les met à disposition
au premier de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la région ile de france a pour ambition
d'équiper 100 % du territoire en
véhicules propres d'ici 2030
il ya des modes de transports
alternatifs ce lieu a notamment pour
objectif de les promouvoir l'aiguillage
a été inauguré samedi dernier à saint
rémy les chevreuse tout près de la gare
rer b pour en parler ils vendent valmont
soir bonsoir
vous êtes le président du parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
dont fait partie justement à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse 53 communes en
tout compose ce territoire à cheval sur
les yvelines et l'essonne et
l'aiguillage c'est à la fois un office
du patrimoine du tourisme est aussi un
pôle de l'écomobilité pourquoi le
fallait il absolument cet équipement
pour le parc
bah c'est l'une des missions des parcs
naturels régionaux on a un très très
beau territoire
on est en bonne partie financé par la
région qui représente plus de la moitié
de nos ressources est l'une de nos
missions principales c'est le
développement du tourisme c'est de
permettre aux franciliens parce que
c'est assez largement un public
francilien
c'est de leur offrir des moyens de
découvrir ce territoire combien a coûté
d'équipement c'est un équipement qui a
coûté 450 mille euros à la région et on
a eu également une subvention
significative de l'état du ministère de
l'environnement pour plus de cent mille
euros et l'aiguillage ce nom a été
choisi par les habitants de ce qu'il y
avait six noms qui étaient au lit il ya
eu une sorte de référendum sur facebook
d'accord et l issue du référendum c'est
le terme de l'aiguillage qui a été
retenu alors pour le pôle éco mobilité
il ya des locations de vélos notamment
assistance électrique y sont proposées
sur place
un garage également pour ses vélos un
atelier de réparation et aussi la
possibilité de louer des véhicules
électriques des petites renault twizy
vous lisez ça fait partie des missions
du parc de promouvoir ce type de
transport alternatifs préserver aussi
finalement le patrimoine
préserver l'environnement si on avait
l'an dernier on a signé un nouveau
contrat entre le parc naturel régional
et la région ile de france et on nous a
demandé de faire un effort important sur
le développement des nouvelles formes de
mobilité on faisait depuis longtemps les
gens on avançait je suis retour ce qui
était réseau doux mais ce n'était pas
suffisant donc là on va beaucoup plus
loin
donc effectivement cette maison de
l'écomobilité elle est située juste à
côté de la gare du rer qui est la
principale porte d'entrée
l'une des principales portes d'entrée du
parc on est à 45 minutes du centre de
paris et c'était une opportunité à
saisir que cette ancienne maison de
garde barrière qui était qu'ils
n'étaient plus utilisés qui n'avait plus
d'usagers donc c'était l'occasion à la
fois d'en faire une filature il met
surtout en même temps de promouvoir des
mobilités douces pour découvrir le
territoire
on a fait appel un délégataire parce que
c'est pas notre métier de louer des
vélos
donc on a une petite entreprise privée
qui à l'issue d'une mise en concurrence
va assurer ce service est que à côté on
a un office de tourisme et derrière on
est en train de développer les voies
douces qui vont permettre aux gens et
également les itinéraires que l'on
mettra sur sur notre site internet vous
pourrez découvrir ce parcours vélo vous
le disais c'est un lieu stratégique on
est tout proche de 7 ce terminus de la
ligne b du rer et c'est le lieu de
départ de plusieurs voix douce et saad
et moi d'où ce qu'il existe déjà depuis
de longues années une liaison que nous
allons d'ailleurs rénové qui permet de
rejoindre par exemple directement le
mesnil saint denis donc ça c'est assez
intéressant et surtout on est en train
de travailler pas plus tard cet après
midi avec la communauté de communes de
limours les voisins parce que c'est une
seule once l'essonne parce qu'en fait
ils sont situés sur une voie ferrée qui
auparavant
non seulement rejoignait
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse d'un côté mais
surtout genre côté aller jusqu à
chartres en passant par lee moore d'une
part et par bonnel d'accord c'est à dire
qu'elle permet de relier le nord au sud
du parc
il ya également alors c'est la route
l'ancienne route de la vélo ceni c'est
ça qui relie paris au mont saint michel
alors on est sur l'itinéraire un des
hits isabella orsini quand elles
s'étendront l'avait losséni en fait qui
relie paris au mont saint michel est
doublée et donc ça va permettre de créer
en plus un barreau qui va permettre
effectivement de relier ces deux
itinéraires de la veille losséni et donc
ça va j'irai encore enrichir l'offre
pour les cyclotouristes donc un pôle éco
mobilité un pôle tourisme également avec
ses 53 communes pour ce parc naturel
régional qui s'étend sur 64 1600
hectares il ya un patrimoine naturel et
un patrimoine historique qui est riche
sur ce territoire et qui méritent d'être
découverts on a on est en train
de faire des travaux extrêmement
importants dans la réserve naturelle
régionale de saint rémy on travaille
également on a offert au public depuis
de longues années également un très beau
circuit dans le marais de ma cour qui
est d'ailleurs connue et très fréquenté
et puis tout récemment on a un très
riche patrimoine culturel tout le monde
le sait mais le château de dampierre a
rouvert ses portes le week-end dernier
ce qui pour nous est une excellente
nouvelle parce que ça vient enrichir
déjà un potentiel considérable il y
avait peu royal des champs châtelot
château de verteuil le château de
braives madeleine le site des vaux de
cernay
donc ça vient s'ajouter déjà une liste
très longue de documents je pense que un
cyclotouriste effectivement peut faire
un petit détour est resté quelques jours
à découvrir tout ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant avec chevreuse
un dernier mot peut-être sur l'actualité
du pnr il ya eu le lancement récemment
d'une monnaie une monnaie locale la
racine c'est ça c'est ça fait partie des
principales actualités
on a actuellement quelques centaines de
commerçants ou d'entreprises qui ont
accepté donc ça se développe lentement
en suisse était c'est une expérience et
on la suit avec le plus grand intérêt on
la soutient bien évidemment merci
allez-y wi lan née en a également
beaucoup d'autres joueurs accueillis sur
les ondes et aussi notamment on est en
train de lancer un grand programme pour
développer l'énergie photovoltaïque sur
le territoire parce que aujourd'hui il
faut bien développer les énergies
renouvelables parce qu'on a besoin
d'énergie d'une façon or on a un beau
potentiel en utilisant notamment les
toitures des écoles des entreprises sans
évidemment à les mettre au sol
on va pas abîmer notre patrimoine
naturel donc c'est l'un des autres
dossiers du territoire merci ils vendent
va c'est beaucoup de résidents du parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse et toute l'actualité toutes
les informations sur ce territoire a
retrouvé bien sûr sur son site internet
l'actualité en bref rappelez vous la
semaine dernière l'un des murs
d'enceinte de la maison centrale de
poissy s'effondrait du côté de l'avenue
des ursulines occasionnant la fermeture
à la circulation depuis ce mardi matin
l'ex a rouvert dans les deux sens mais
reste interdite aux poids lourds et aux
bus et dans un communiqué le maire karl
olive demande désormais à l'état une
vérification de tous les murs d'enceinte
de la prison afin de prévenir
d'éventuels autres incidents
le déploiement de la fibre optique se
poursuit dans les yvelines et se
concrétise dans les yvelines rural dès
ce mois d'avril et dix communes du nord
du département vont être raccordés au
très haut débit à des offres
d'abonnement seront proposées aux
habitants des poètes et ce en cours ou
encore condé sur vègre un choix à faire
parmi à cinq opérateurs on met une
vingtaine d'autres villages
bénéficieront de la fibre l'objectif
affiché à 100 % de foyers yvelinois
relier à l'horizon 2021
on poursuit notre dossier de la semaine
consacrée à l'union européenne le 26 mai
prochain les français sont appelés à
élire 79 euro députés à travers un
scrutin à la proportionnelle des listes
candidates est de partis et mouvements
différents dès qu'ils sont déjà donc
déclarer le tour d'horizon avec nicolas
d'andrus plus ou moins d'europe en
fonction des listes électorales c'est le
dilemme proposé aux français le 26 mai
prochain
différents projets pour l'union
européenne présentées par les mouvements
politiques portées par nathalie l'oiseau
la liste renaissance va défendre le
projet d' emmanuel macron avec notamment
l'harmonisation de certaines politiques
sur la défense européenne sur le
bouclier social sur tout un tas de deux
choses il ya des pays qui veulent
avancer
on le voit aussi sur la taïga femmes par
exemple il ya des pays qui ne veulent
pas avancer parce qu'elles ont des
avantages et qu'elles ont choisi d'avoir
une politique
et puis d'autres qui veulent avancer
différemment et donc l'idée c'est ça
c'est d'essayer d'avancer sur tous les
sujets sur lesquels on peut aller
ensemble ou en tout cas à réunir une
majorité face au projet présidentiel les
républicains présente une liste menée
par françois-xavier bel ami avec la
volonté de défendre une europe
pragmatique à travers des projets
concrets à l'échelle européenne
aujourd'hui l'europe elle ne convainc
plus les français parce que elle semble
inefficace parce qu'elle donne
l'impression d'être quelque chose qui
contribue à cette dépossession
collective et donc il faut absolument
redonner sens à l'europe parce que nous
avons besoin d'europe dans la
mondialisation à gauche yannick jadot
porte sa liste europe écologie les verts
dans cette candidature libinois mounir
satouri leur projet un traité
environnemental européen et la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
nous défendrons à sedan dans le cadre de
cette campagne à protectionnisme vert
aux frontières de l'europe
ce n'est plus possible de continuer à
importer en europe des produits qu'ils
sont
fabriqués ou aux produits dans des
conditions écologiques lamentable la
france insoumise participera aussi à ce
scrutin avec un programme basé sur
plusieurs piliers européen
1 la transition écologique totale de
l'économie
2 un modèle social européen qui soit le
modèle le plus exigeant disponibles
qu'on puisse imaginer par exemple avec
un smic européen qui soit au même niveau
dans toute l'europe etc
face à ces différents projets d'autres
mouvements politiques sont orientées sur
d'autres modèles d'europe
le rassemblement national avec la tête
de liste jordan bardella défend lui une
europe des nations
elle repose sur plusieurs thématiques en
ce qui nous concerne la défense des
frontières en premier lieu que ce soit
contre l'immigration ou contre les
travailleurs détachés elles reposent
aussi sur la défense des des français du
système français qui est mise à mal par
l'union européenne et puis enfin elle
défend le localisme c'est à dire la
lutte contre une certaine forme de
mondialisation qui fait qu'on se
retrouve avec des ogm dans nos assiettes
même longueur d'onde pour le mouvement
debout la france de nicolas dupont
aignan prenant lui des coopérations
entre les états européens la france est
est la septième puissance mondiale et
n'a pas nécessairement besoin au niveau
de sa diplomatie ou de son économie
d'être porté par un ensemble plus vaste
plus lourds comme l'union l'union
européenne
d'autres listes seront aussi présentés
aux français avec lui des i de jean
christophe lagarde
le parti socialiste allié au mouvement
place publique de raphaël glucksmann le
parti communiste de ian brossât
génération point est menée par benoît
hamon ou encore lui pr2 françois
asselineau et son projet deux fréq site
autre élection les municipales qui se
dérouleront l'an prochain les candidats
se font connaître à trappes guy
malandain le maire sortant a déjà fait
part de sa nouveau de son sa volonté
pardon elle d'aller dans un nouveau
mandat mustapha larfaoui s'engage aussi
dans la campagne il tenait une
conférence de presse cet après midi dans
le quartier des merisiers pour annoncer
à la création de son association
engagement trappe c'est justement du
monde associatif que vient le pharmacien
ex président de l'étoile sportive de
trappes président de formats citoyens sa
fan harbaoui réfléchi pour le moment à
se présenter comme tête de liste
soit comme colistier d'un autre candidat
pour ce scrutin les propos sont
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude en 15 ans j'ai eu le sentiment
d'avoir été adopté par cette ville
je veux maintenant mais engagés donc on
a créé une association pour ça est ce
que je souhaite faire maintenant c'est
m'engager sur le terrain pour aller à la
rencontre des habitants des trappistes
donc j'arrive maintenant à un point de
convergence ou l'associatif est un bilan
je peux apporter
l'entreprise est un bilan également et
aujourd'hui je trouve que l'action
l'action on va dire pour le bien public
e
quelque chose qui m'attire parce qu'il
ya des effets leviers que je n'avais pas
dans l'associatif que je pourrais avoir
j'imagine grâce à une mairie c'est une
première le 4 mai prochain la ville de
versailles accueillera la biennale
d'architecturé de paysage de la région
ile de france une manifestation où se
mêlera débats rencontres et expositions
aux quatre coins de la cité royale la
présentation avait lieu ce matin à paris
aux délires 11 étaient sur place
bape trois lettres pour découvrir l'
architecture à travers des lieux de
patrimoine des colloques ou encore des
expositions la première biennale
d'architecturé de paysage de la région
ile de france ouvrira ses portes le 4
mai prochain à versailles un moment de
réflexion autour de ce thème l'homme
la ville et la nature la grande
interrogation aujourd'hui et du moment
en terme d'urbanisme
c'est le mariage entre la nature et
l'urbain et ça c'est devenu une question
prioritaire contenu de la préoccupation
écologique et donc tous les architectes
ou les urbanistes pensent différemment
depuis le début de ce nouveau millénaire
et ont mis la préoccupation
environnementale au coeur de leurs
travaux durant soixante et onze jours le
public pourra notamment à découvrir six
expositions réparties sur plusieurs
lieux au château de versailles
au potager du roi dans les écoles
nationales supérieures d'architecturé du
paysage
le choix de la cité royale pour
accueillir cette biennale s'est presque
imposé de lui même
la m ici dans cette école d'architecturé
cette école du paysage dans cette avenue
de paris où il y aura une lime qui sera
ordinaire et expositions photos la
relier au château de versailles au
potager du roi ça faisait du sens
et puis évidemment nous avons à
versailles des centaines de milliers de
touristes ce qui fait des centaines de
milliers de visiteurs potentiels pour la
biennale
lors de ce rendez vous le public pourra
également découvrir les projets les
ambitions du grand paris express lors
d'une exposition au sein de l'ancienne
poste
[Musique]
et pour le coup de coeur culture
direction une autre cité royale saint
germain en laye vont sans mélanie
politesse pour ça une ville donc et
surtout une famille qui a régné sur la
france
et oui alors cette dynastie à l'araignée
de 13/100 28 à 15 189
je veux bien sûr parler des valois et de
membres de cette famille sont à
l'honneur à saint-germain-en-laye henri
ii et marguerite de valois
tous les deux sont nés dans la cité
yvelinoise qu il en rend hommage alors
pour le père henry 2 direction le
château le musée d'archéologie nationale
lui consacre une exposition à l'occasion
du 500e anniversaire de sa naissance
pour rappel henry 2 est le deuxième fils
de françois 1er
il n'était pas destiné à régner mais son
frère françois décès dans quinze 136
il devient donc dauphin pour accéder au
trône en 15 147 il sera roi du rhône
douzaine d'années écouter ce que vous
allez pouvoir découvrir dans cette
exposition la personnalité dans les deux
bien sûr qu'il découvrira au travers de
nombreuses oeuvres à la fois concernant
directement henri ii également la
production artistique sous henri deux
ans dans l'entourage du roi mais
également l'un des propos majeures de
l'exposition
et de souligner l'importance de la
présence d'henri ii ici même à saint
germain en laye qui devient durant son
règne la principale résidence du roi
dans une histoire de soi qui est assez
méconnue par rapport à celle de son père
le célèbre françois 1er aussi une
célèbre bataille marignons fameux 15
115ème est l'un des épisodes du règne
d'henri ii a donné une exposition une
expression à sierentz est une expression
lire aussi une exposition bien d'avoir
une expression
oui c'était d'expression qui vient d'un
duel un reflet d'une féroce rivalité
entre l'entourage du roi et celui de son
père une rivalité qui va amener au
fameux duel opposant la châtaigneraie le
proche d'andy et jarnac alors le dernier
le vainqueur surprise de par un coup
surprenant dans le jarret une histoire
que l'on peut redécouvrir pour cette
exposition qui dure donc jusqu'au 14
juillet et les valois entretien inspiré
malanje un chorégraphe
oui si je vous dit marguerite de valois
et qui pensez vous la reine margot la
reine margot bien sûr le célèbre roman
d'alexandre dumas publié en 1845
mais aussi le film de patrice chéreau de
cas de 1994 avec isabelle adjani et
daniel auteuil marguerite de valois rens
rires alors le chorégraphe dont vous
parlais tout à l'heure grégory c'est
régis obadia sa dernière création ce
nombre cinq romans reine margot une
pièce d'un peu plus d'une heure et j'ai
sauvé à de vialas créé à la demande du
directeur du théâtre alexandre dumas qui
fête cette année ses 30 ans histoire de
margaux est dure et violente rappelez
vous vos cours d'histoire
marguerite épouse henri de navarre henri
iv quelques jours avant la saint
barthélémy et le chorégraphe lui a
choisi surtout de faire parler les
émotions sont nés dans la danse
contemporaine
donc c'est une narration mais c'est pas
une narration classique
donc il ya par moments je pense les gens
vont reconnaître les personnages par un
moment il un t il incarne un caractère
un personnage entre guillemets et
d'autres moments ils sont dix ans plus
abstrait c'est c'est le langage c'est la
danse qui parle alors la première de
reine margot c'est le 11 avril prochain
au théâtre alexandre dumas et c'est un
20h40 et pas besoin d'attendre autant
pour retrouver mélanie poker et son
émission le 7-8 culture puisque c'est
après ce journal merci mélanie on va
refermer d'ailleurs cette édition avec
mon autre invité guillaume durand
bonsoir bon sens vous êtes le
responsable événementiel de l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines le
site qui organise le week-end prochain
tous à lille deux jours de portes
ouvertes pour découvrir ou redécouvrir
et les activités à faire sur place des
animations spéciales sont également
prévus c'est la troisième édition de cet
événement c'est intéressant pour vous de
proposer chaque année
voilà une re découverte des activités
possibles à faire à lille de loisirs
effectivement bien que 1000 de loisirs
est ouverte toute l'année
les portes ouvertes c'est vraiment
marque le lancement de saison
le visage et le paysage de ligne de
loisirs peut changer d'une année à
l'autre il est important pour nous de
faire redécouvrir et découvrir cet hymne
de loisirs à tous vous visiez lancement
de saison si là on va rentrer dans la
saison estivale on rentre dans la saison
estivale c'est ça faire à partir de
maintenant vraiment l'ensemble des
activités sont ouvertes
effectivement la saison estivale va
commencer rapidement et quel genre de
d'activité quel genre de dit quelle
différence finalement liga avec la
saison hivernale il ya des activités
différentes qui sont proposées auraient
effectivement pour des besoins
d'entretien du matériel comme au niveau
du parcours accrobranche
on a besoin de fermer sur une période
hivernale de manière à faire une
un entretien du matériel vérification
également des différents parcours voilà
pour certaines raisons on se doit de
fermer certains certaines activités
est ce que c'est un rendez vous tous à
lille qui avait tir à chaque fois du
public qui attire du monde
oui effectivement c'est un rendez vous
qui rassemble beaucoup de personnes
l'édition précédente a rassemblé plus de
8000 participants sur l'ensemble du
week-end donc c'est c'est une événement
qui plaît beaucoup aux saint quentinois
et aux franciliens les objectifs
finalement s'est présenté ce panel
d'activités les les redécouvrir que ça
soit un événement festif c'est sale et
les objectifs de ce week-end où est
complètement alors tous à lille c'est
aussi des animations spéciales notamment
n'ont pas l'orient-express mais c'est un
escape game alors je n'ai plus le jeu
n'est plus le nom s'est orientée skype
l'orienter skype tout simplement voilà
j'ai essayé un petit jeunot c'est un
escape game qui est proposée ce week end
c'est un format d'escale viennent un peu
arrangé sur un format grandeur nature il
ya de l'orientation la réflexion des
énigmes à résoudre sur un format de deux
heures d'activité environ dont il ya
deux activités qui sont proposées
spécifiquement lors de ce week end est
partie ouverte donc l'orienter skype qui
malheureusement l'ensemble des créneaux
à son ensemble est au complet
cette activité est l'autre activité où
il ya des créneaux encore disponibles
c'est des initiations au paddle voilà
dès l'initiation aux pédales de 14h à
17h30 le samedi et le dimanche sur des
initiations d'une demi heure et c'est
aussi l'occasion de pouvoir faire du
paddle sur un site assez intéressant qui
est le plus grand plan d'eau d'île de
france
cet étang de l'île de loisirs
effectivement ça permet de découvrir
ligne de loisirs sous un autre angle
depuis hier les temps et sur les ondes
de ligne de loisirs en plus de ces deux
activités est aussi un village accueille
activité qui sera proposée au coeur du
parc promenade qu'est-ce qu'on pourra y
retrouver dans ce village
alors c'est déjà un point d'accueil et
d'information pour l'ensemble des
usagers qui viendront sur l'hymne de
loisirs des activités également
gratuites seront proposées comme de
l'initiation au disc golf avec un
parcours de 8 paniers
il n'y en aura notamment un
un practice qui sera mis en place par
blue green le golf régional qui est déjà
présent sur l'île des loisirs est
également d'initiation à de la
trottinette électrique et enfin des
tours en calèche également la saison
estivale qui débute c'est aussi le
retour de certaines animations certaines
activités par exemple le benji éjection
qui revient c'est ça ça a été ça a été
un succès en 2018 ça revient cette année
à lille de loisirs gentiment cette
activité a été reconduite et vous
pourrez la découvrir lors de son
lancement de saison avec l'ouverture du
parcours accrobranche et notamment on
met en place des offres commerciales
tout le long de ce week-end avec les
entrées gratuites au niveau de ligne de
loisirs au niveau des véhicules et au
niveau des offres commerciales également
sur certaines activités une place
achetée une place offerte et on retrouve
bien sûr toutes les informations sur le
site de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines merci guillaume
durand d'être ça c'est sur ce plateau
aride responsable événementiel pour
cette île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines le 7-8 journal touche à sa fin
ces reportages l'édition complète à
retrouver bien sûr sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]